Marvel has officially confirmed an
insane Captain America theory that
answers a lot of questions that we had
after Avengers endgame how's it going
everybody it's Warren and if you were
wondering and a little bit confused
about what Captain America did when he
went back in time and if you were
wondering if there were two Captain
America's existing in the same timeline
well we finally have some answers for
you we are learning a lot more about
Avengers and game since its digital
release for example the reason that the
door was open to the house that Peggy
Carter and Steve Rogers were dancing in
was because that was when Steve Rogers
first arrived that means the first thing
that Peggy Carter and Steve Rogers did
when he arrived and revealed himself to
her was to have that dance and now
thanks to the writers of Avengers in
game we now have confirmation on a major
Captain America theory so let's break
down everything the writers have said
about Captain America going back in time
also a quick reminder if you'd like a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 be sure
to subscribe to my channel like the
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain I'm
picking a new winner at 500,000
subscribers so one of the biggest
questions about Captain America going
back in time and staying back in time
was is there - Captain America's in that
timeline now and if so how did that work
well the writers have officially told us
how exactly it worked out writer Stephen
McFeely said here's how we reconcile it
we think that there have always been two
caps from 1945 to say now and we just
didn't know that that's the loop right
it's not back to the future rules it's
branch reality rules this is not
stepping on a butterfly that turns the
world's into bifs Casino you can't alter
your future by going back to the past we
sort of created our own time travel
rules wherein as the ancient one says if
you remove an infinity stone from a time
line that creates a branch reality it
jumped to 1948 and decided to stay so
his younger self is on ice somewhere and
it's only in 2011 that there are
technically two steve's running around
to the point where if you were to look
closely at Peggy's funeral there'd be an
old man in the back named Roger Stephens
now this is the writers confirming a
major Captain America Theory obviously
this old man named Roger Stephens is
just Steve Rogers in disguise taking on
the name Roger Stephens so nobody
knows that he is in fact Steve Rogers
from the future but the writers have
officially confirmed that there have
always been - Steve Rogers in the same
timeline and they have officially
confirmed that the Captain America that
went back in time was at Peggy Carter's
funeral that took place in the present
time in that moment a time in which the
present Captain America of that time was
there as well
now if Captain America going back in
time and staying there created a branch
reality this should not be possible
however they do explain this a little
bit they claim that the ancient one says
that only removing an infinity stone
creates a branched reality well when
Captain America went back in time he
returned all of the Infinity stones
there for a branch reality should not
have been created which means that
Captain America going back in time would
mean that he stayed in the same MCU
timeline not a branched reality
confirming the fact that Steve Rogers
was in fact Peggy Carter's husband that
was mentioned in the Winter Soldier and
he was in fact at her funeral in Captain
America's Civil War this is certainly a
very different take on what we all
expected especially the branch reality
explanation but it does confirm this
amazing incredible theory Captain
America gets to go back in time be with
the love of his life marry her and have
kids without affecting the future
Captain America because eventually the
future Captain America will get to do
the same thing and this is a great way
to end the story for Captain America he
gets everything that he finally deserves
so although the writers explanation of
this branched reality in Captain America
going back in time may be a little bit
spotty it is nice to know that Captain
America and Peggy Carter did get their
happy ending so let me know what you
think about the writers confirming this
crazy Captain America Theory leave your
thoughts in the comments down below and
don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like the
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter the giveaway and stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof